up dog
i'm not as excited as you are what the
[ __ ] you've been all weekend i had a
great week and i went to la jolla
yesterday sure sure just for the day
it was fun i wasn't gonna do anything at
home walked around yeah our buddy owns a
burrito place down there uh
don uh don carlos and we just went we
had a burrito one got some gelato and
walked around the uh cove it was fun
come on yeah what what am i gonna do up
here i live in california i might as
well go down by the beach you bad
[ __ ] today
today uh we watched a new show which
actually you might like on netflix i'm
sure everyone's hitting up narcos have
you heard about that how is it it's
actually pretty [ __ ] good
um
we've got like the three or four
episodes of that and that's it man just
had a fun weekend
today not today yesterday i did
no sun today none today no sun on sunday
no sun i went to the mother-in-law's for
dinner what's she cooked on garlic
shrimp oh so good good shrimp she got
those little small they're smaller but
they're good
ones out of a can no i don't think
they're in a candy you never [ __ ]
know these people
they're savages nowadays they'll give
you a little dollar shrimp you got to
eat it next thing you know you're
[ __ ] while you're eating
that's so hot what's happening you sexy
[ __ ] cake quickly they're
talented thanks joey not much i chilled
all day i just bet i was lazy as [ __ ] i
sat around my house i feel actually i
didn't even go to the gym which i do
every day really you go to the gym every
day i do something or i like play
volleyball or i play outside i hike yeah
but nothing today where do you live
hollywood i live in east hollywood in
thai town
you know it yeah like hollywood and
western
western right there yeah it's crazy over
there but
he goes for dumplings over there and
[ __ ] do you in koreatown town yeah
there's good food in koreatown thai town
too actually i like that's why i like it
joey said i'm not allowed to eat there
because there's no stray cats walking
around you have to look in those in
those neighborhoods you have to look for
a straight cat that's how you know the
food's authentic is that it well like
you know because if there's no stray
cats that's what they're cooking that's
what they do oh my god that little white
meat that's hilarious i haven't seen any
cats cooking but i could be lived over
there i've lived there two and a half
years about and how long have you lived
in los angeles since 06. i moved here in
2006. but it kind of i didn't live here
the whole time i moved here and then uh
there was three years when i had this
job where i used to emcee events
actually for sports illustrated and for
nascar so i used to travel and i would
be like on the girl on stage basically
like interviewing athletes or drivers
and like throwing t-shirts out to the
audience i did that for three years full
time on the road that's [ __ ] nuts it
was super fun actually i met so many
cool people like i'm not really a nascar
fan but i love nascar fans because
they're crazy so that time i spent on
the road i got to meet so many like
crazy drunk guys and their their wives
nascar wives are the coolest women have
you ever been to a nascar race never
never it's insane because i used to i
worked with miller lite and i was like
on a nascar miller like poster at the
time and so i would go to all these
events i would emcee and sign posters
and you would think that you know wives
wouldn't want their husbands like coming
up to us and hanging out and flirting
but these wives would like shove their
husbands at us and be like can he just
touch your boob for a photo can you just
grab your i was like these women are
[ __ ] crazy
but i love them it was a lot how did you
get that job out of l.a or
you're originally from ohio i'm from
ohio did you start comedy in ohio no i
started doing improv when i was in
college in chicago i went to school in
chicago started doing improv there i
didn't start doing stand up till i moved
to la in like 07.
and where'd you go to school in chicago
i went to this school called roosevelt
university it's like uh it's like a
performing arts college downtown small
and what's your major in i was an acting
major i was a theater arts major in
college i think it's so funny now for
some reason looking back because at the
time i was so serious about like
dramatic you know how theater people are
they're very like intense about like
being an actor and it's very like a
[ __ ] hat with a loop-de-loop yeah
totally i will never forget my first day
at uh roosevelt because i got a
scholarship there actually so when i
went to audition for my scholarship they
gave me a tour of the school and i'll
never forget i walked in to this class
that was happening it was called vocal
and physical prep it was like 20 actors
like 20 kids basically they're playing
music and the kids were blindfolded and
it looked like an orgy they're all like
crawling all over each other and like
their hands are on each other like
feeling each other's body and i asked
the teacher i go like what are they
doing and they were like they're getting
in touch with their insides and i was
like this is a college class like this
is what's gonna happen here and she was
like yeah this is one of the required
courses sophomore year and i was like
i'm going to this school like this is
insane
so i went there but now looking back i
just find it hilarious because you go to
uh
uh performing arts high school
i think they have those now like what
the [ __ ] is about
i never knew what the [ __ ] that was
somebody told me that their daughter's
transferring
i kind of did i don't know a chartered
performing artist yeah yeah and i'm
thinking to myself it's like fame people
running around jumping up and down the
hallways and singing
breaking into dance that's how my
college was for sure my high school i
did go to a i kind of did like my um
senior year of high school there was an
option to like go into a vocational
theater arts program that was yeah it
was basically a whole bunch all the
schools in the county came together
and there was a theater arts program you
could specialize in so i did that my
senior year high school it was the only
reason i graduated though
i would never have made it through
because i dropped out i was so bored of
school i dropped out of high school
actually and then i the only reason i
went back was because they had that
program i was like all right i guess i
can make it through if i can be in there
i took one [ __ ] performing arts class
all four years of high school intro to
performing arts
my freshman year the teacher was a
lesbian
she was pretty [ __ ] cool she was
short
we [ __ ] around like not [ __ ] like
we [ __ ] around the class like we went
in there basically to [ __ ] around
and uh one day she goes you know i have
an assignment for you guys to pass you
have to do an assignment this this is
not just jokes and [ __ ] yeah
you guys cracking jokes you have to do
something
you have to go up on stage and do a
reading or do shakespeare or do stand-up
comedy and i didn't know what the [ __ ]
to do
and i said okay and i went up there
and i put on shattered by the stones and
i lip-synched it and danced
she gave me a [ __ ] and i blew the
class up i would love to see that now
looking like jesus you know they don't
tape know this
but after he said this performing arts
thing i remember driving to the airport
yesterday morning thinking of
where did i pick this [ __ ] up like where
did this thing start
in the sixth grade we had this teaching
named mr levito and he used to have a
wig and miss lavito all for years you
thought he was one of those he was a
feminine guy
you know yeah he was married he had kids
and he was just a sweetheart of a guy
so he was also part of the ecology club
so if you were part of the ecology club
you left school at one o'clock
you had options you had options on
friday yeah so on fridays you could
leave at 12 but you had to go to holy
rosary and take ccd
class which is set up there with a
priest and he talks to you about the
catholic religion for two hours before
confirmation or you could be part of the
ecology club
or you could sit in a class with a bunch
of dunces and levito would talk to you
so i was part of the ecology class but i
also [ __ ] around with the vetoes thing
and one day he's like you know let's put
some music on one of the girls let's put
music on this is like a a wild type
independent class when we put music on
and i went up on stage on the front of
the class by the destiny i just started
singing frankie valley my eyes adored
you right
and that was it
like every friday what year this is 19
75 i'm 12.
i got to be 12. i just clicked for you
that was it you were like i love this i
love doing this no no but it was with
music yeah like i would just put music
on and go up there and sing frankie
valley with music and people would clap
and [ __ ] and then i would switch it up
to michael jackson and then i got put in
the band with dean lapree
john ben and this dude ray canella who
calls him for the podcast today still he
worked for [ __ ] he worked for sci-fi
for 30 years ray can ellen quit and
opened up his own sci-fi [ __ ] youtube
channel so this is how far back we go
the sixth grade these four more runs
that's awesome we used to go there play
beatles songs and just play over the
beat like that was our band and one day
we had like this big show and these
girls came in and we started playing
they're like
cut like what the [ __ ] guys you guys are
in a band
you're playing so and they just walked
out and we fired the bass play and that
was the end of our [ __ ] band now
hilarious because it was his idea to put
the [ __ ] songs that's so funny but
that's i didn't know anything about
performing arts i didn't even know i was
performing
i had no [ __ ] idea i just thought
that everybody did it you know i don't
know nothing i don't know because paper
doesn't seem like something you'd enjoy
performing arts like you like i know you
act now but just knowing your
personality and what you did in your
younger days doesn't seem like you'd be
going up for plays and
and and all that stuff i like the acting
i really really do like the acting
but i don't like that part of the acting
the breathing exercise well that's the
thing i was going to say yeah four-year
universities here on santa monica
and you know even acting classes there's
some acting classes in that way
that are basically cults
totally they're just little little cults
and havana chubby is the main main one
yeah yeah she has a little i mean what
she does over there is
like [ __ ] brutality to kids
it just shocks you because they're not
top skin like us we have stand up skin
right stand up skin to have stand up
skin
you had to go through [ __ ] somewhere
along the line so true
stand up skin is a little thicker than
acting skin oh for sure acting skin they
run around scared with stand ups you do
go [ __ ] your mother i got the club down
the corner i'll stand in that club until
i get really funny and i'll still eat
your [ __ ] lunch so stand up uh skins
a little thicker these kids at this
place on highland she abuses them like
they have to intern for free they have
to pay [ __ ] classes you know she
tells you when you're ready to audition
well it's no like that's so funny it's
so funny that you said that because i
always say
when i first moved to la i wanted to act
right and i used to go on auditions
whatever and every once in a while i'd
get something but it wasn't like going
great and i started doing comedy and
then i loved stand-up and i really just
stopped caring about acting i mean i
still like enjoyed it but you go to
auditions and you'll still [ __ ] them up
if you have to yeah but i just didn't
care like stand up became like i was
like oh this is what i'm supposed to be
doing this is what i love and then what
happened is i just did stand up for a
few years and i really kind of pretty
much quit acting and then i started
getting a lot of auditions because
people would see me doing stand-up and
then when i started going to my
auditions and completely not giving a
[ __ ] i swear to god
i started booking everything
i remember the first uh i think it was
the first sag job i booked actually i
went in i wasn't supposed to have an
audition that day my agent called me at
the last minute she's like can you be
there in like 15 minutes i was like i
just left the gym i looked like [ __ ] it
was supposed to be to play like a sexy
college student
i'm like i'll go but and and the girl
was supposed to have like a jewish
accent from brooklyn or something it was
totally the wrong role for me right i'm
like i mean i'll go i'm right there i'll
just swing by and do it i took a
headshot i wrote on the back of the
headshot a couple credits with a sharpie
and my phone number because i didn't
even have a resume on me and i went in
and gave it to them i was like sorry i
was at the gym i didn't know about this
and i read and i left and i got it and
forever after that i would always go
into auditions with that attitude which
is just like i'd read over the lines a
few times and give it my best shot but i
really just didn't care anymore because
i care so much more about my stage time
in town
and now i do pretty i you almost always
at least get a callback like it's so
crazy interesting when you
make that transition and you you the
stand-up skin helps you later on
stand up skin and you can tell when you
meet people and they're like oh this
isn't going great
i don't know how long i'll make it and
they disappear and they pop up on
facebook they're mowing lawns in
kentucky
and you could tell stand up tough it's a
different you know i used to go to the
first acting class i went to
was this guy on monday nights
frank and he was on gardner
gardner stages not downstairs but on the
side
it's still there monday nights
seven to nine
and he was a great teacher you know he
taught different [ __ ] and then i i said
[ __ ] this [ __ ] because i couldn't sit
there monday nights and in the late 90s
was the hottest stand-up night oh yeah
yeah the last fracture latino night you
had the [ __ ] improv was freaky monday
freaky monday was a white show that
turned into a black show i love that
okay so it's eight from eight to eight
thirty five white guys on
at 8 35 a strong white guy would go up
yeah yeah and then at 8 50 it became
[ __ ] you know depth chant yeah and it
was uh off the charts awesome tucker
with all those guys and then the comm
but monday nights and then what you
strive to do in those days was to get a
triple crown
like i would get the improv yeah and
then i would shoot over to the store and
i would get latino night the last factor
i should have just once every six weeks
you got the improv the laugh at you wow
yeah and 805 and 820 oh are you kidding
me i'm out of that by nine o'clock and i
could play all three clubs so frank used
to get pissed so he i stopped going to
frank huh and then i hooked up with a
black gay guy that had aids
and he was way towards the end he was on
hollywood and gower up that street like
if i'm on sunset instead of making a
right if i'm going east instead of
making a right towards the studios and
make a left towards hollywood boulevard
he was in those little shacks
and he had a couple guys going in he'd
be coughing a napkin he was towards the
end
he had the h is this a joke this is not
a [ __ ] joke do you lower his prices
20 bucks an hour he was [ __ ]
tremendous
he was a great coach that's a guy who
coached me like my big big thing
i swear to god you said you know these
people i i answered an ad like there was
another i bet you did it was like uh
coach acting coach 35 bucks or something
and i went to him a couple of times and
i hit up with him and then he told me
the truth because i have aids and
whatever i don't know if i'm going to
live but i was one of the best acting
coaches in this town in the 70s
blah blah blah i was open-minded to him
and then one day i called listen to how
tough he was one day i called him at 9
30 and i go
i got the biggest audition of my life i
don't know i'm gonna do this he goes you
know you're gonna do this
you're gonna [ __ ] go and get some
soup for me and then come to my house
feed me the soup and i'll help you with
the lines oh and that was the travolta
movie that i almost got but then
travolta pulled out to do the
scientology movie
and then i went to miami and i did a
bunch of [ __ ] when i came back i lost
contact with the guy he was just a
little black dude you've lost contact
with him forever you've never heard of
him again never never i lost that i had
i had a
[ __ ] thing of numbers and i had the
car parked and the registration was
expired the car got towed
and they wouldn't let me back in the car
unless i had the registration title so i
lost everything i went to his apartment
i mean i'm one of those dudes so i'm the
type of guy i'll go to the apartment
knock on the door somebody had rented
they said he moved
no way so i don't know if he was with
his mother because he said he was
thinking of moving with his mother did
you ever get your car back no it wasn't
really my car was somebody else's own
somebody's car got towed and you just
never got it back it's just gone the
[ __ ] you're the second person to tell me
a story like that what the hell is that
and maybe gave josh wolf a car because
she was in love with him she wanted to
suck his dick
so josh wilkes said you borrow the
[ __ ] car
so ann minnie went to new york to work
for some company in new york and manny
was a big hustler for disney then they
fired it because she was half [ __ ]
and then she went to work for fox as a
talent scout and then they fired her
there too and then she went to work she
did a project with the bengals or some
band that i'd rather shoot myself and
listen to their music
and that went under the tubes
so in this process she gave a car to
josh wolf and josh wolf let me use it
but the registration expired so i kept
driving the car but these [ __ ] uh
ladies in hollywood the ticket ladies
would just give me a ticket they were
hunting me down
they would give me tickets i must have
ten thousand tickets shut up finally i
was dating this little dirty stripper
chick up here on sherman way and i went
up there to give her a stab and when i
was taking a shower the car got towed
sorry to give her a stabbing and i got
[ __ ] and i used to live in that car
so in other words my apartment got towed
so i had everything i owned in that car
headshots boxing gloves
resumes clothes
everything from 1995 on do you think
it's still in some impound lot somewhere
no it wasn't it was over at [ __ ] uh
gower for like a month or two what's the
one on guy with it it was there this is
1998
1999 that car is still [ __ ] there
holy [ __ ] it's going to cost more to get
it out it's not that's what it's worth
it's like a time capsule i would just
love to open it like slip something like
20 bucks and just see what you had in
your car mandy headshots boxing gloves
that probably had a coke mirror under
the seat
rolling papers
it was a great little car with great
[ __ ] naked can we talk about living
in your car because no [ __ ] i'm not
kidding i'm thinking about doing this
because i have this idea i i like
camping like i love camping actually
right and hollywood is really expensive
and you have to look really good in
hollywood to work on tv and looking good
is [ __ ] expensive in this town and i
just started thinking that maybe instead
of rent that i should just live in my
car and camp like in malibu or something
and just uh periscope the whole thing
and just be like homeless in hollywood
but then still keep up like all my usual
things that i do like keep my gym
membership going like keep going the
same hairdresser in beverly hills are
you going to look good if you're
sleeping in a car that would be the fun
of the show is that a car you got i got
a suv it's like a hyundai i think i
could make it work and i have a tent for
five people i got an air mattress and i
camped in national parks for 14 weeks
one summer so like i'm really outdoorsy
and i know how to cook on a fire and
then i thought too like guys would think
i'm low maintenance and then you know
they might want to date me more because
they'd be like oh this [ __ ] can live
outside and they'd be into that and i'm
not kidding i'm seriously thinking of
doing it like my lease is up next month
and i'm like why not do it for one month
wouldn't that be great you could get
away with it here i'm just yeah i don't
know ellis home was mad well yeah i feel
[ __ ] scared for you like i wouldn't
sleep at night if i knew you were on a
beach in malibu i wouldn't be on the
beach i'd get a campsite at like a state
park
what's the closest state park around
here i think uh there's one in malibu
it's called like malibu creek or
something yeah they got a waiting list
because everybody wants to live in
[ __ ] malibu
so you're [ __ ] there the palisades has
one too the palisades okay so after all
your sets and [ __ ] at night right you
have to [ __ ] drive to the palace i
would say
campsite get the [ __ ] out but joey then
also sometimes i could crash on people's
couches and sometimes maybe i hook up
with somebody and i sleep at his house i
know that never happens but in my in
this fantasy that happens all the time
and then i'd periscope the whole show i
could get sponsors you know like i could
get like camping companies that like
maybe rei would sponsor me or something
have you lost your [ __ ] do you have a
gun
i have a squirt gun that looks so real
that's not gonna [ __ ] work you squirt
me with a sweater and i'm gonna even get
double piston here
it looks real i keep it in my nightstand
in case someone breaks in
is it filled with water i [ __ ] up with
a beer
somebody jerked off in that thing and
squirted you [ __ ] drove around
squirting and you didn't even know how
fun is that i would love to do something
like that
what is this
ice cream you know
the best part of it is that i keep my
fake gun in my nightstand right next to
this purple vibrator that i have and i
always imagine that like an intruder
breaks in i accidentally grabbed the
wrong thing but then i figured like that
actually if a girl grabbed a vibrator
and like waved that at you when you
broke in you'd probably be more freaked
out and you'd probably leave
do you think she was like psycho you're
like what the [ __ ] is going on i came to
she's pulling the vibrate out and
[ __ ] you just broke my train of
thought that's what would happen what
are you doing over there it's trying to
imagine someone being homeless
and like periscope i'm trying to figure
out how
but there's there are a lot of people
here who do the rv thing and i think i
think it's really interesting it's very
interesting i would if i do it did it i
wouldn't do it in north hudson north
hollywood park yeah why would i have
santa monica i do it at a [ __ ] beach
that's what i'm saying i sleep on the
beach and think about it get an rv just
get someone to give you an rv for a
month yeah yeah plan this out but i mean
you wouldn't be homeless yeah i wanted
to be homeless for real and i think it
would be so funny imagine like last
night i went out for girls night with my
friend and we like dressed up on purpose
because we wanted to like go out and
meet guys how funny would it be to like
do all of that but still be homeless but
have like hot dresses and heels and
makeup but be living you have
disadvantages because i know you too
what happens if you can't wash your
monkey for 12 hours
that's got some wing to it what are you
gonna do then what happens if you're
meeting johnny homeless and now your
monkey smells homeless what are you
gonna do it wouldn't because i would
keep my gym membership and i would
shower at the gym yeah but the gym is
[ __ ] ten miles away so what are you
gonna do if johnny's on the spot right
now are you going to put some water in
that cat
go to the beach
i don't know i haven't all right i
haven't thought that you got to think
all this [ __ ] out because i was homeless
so i [ __ ] know this i don't like
being swelly and my
i like taking showers after i take a
[ __ ] all that when you're me too yeah so
when you're homeless you can't do that
[ __ ] so i was homeless i lived two
blocks from the gym i had to piss out
the window and [ __ ] out the window
because i didn't have a shower there
what oh yeah where were you living in an
office building over josh wolfe's
restaurant in seattle el lobo loco in
1995. so i paid 125 a month for the
office
and i would walk to the end they had a
little bathroom no shower so i would
piss off the thing and i would [ __ ] out
the balcony or i would walk two blocks
and go to the gym and i took two showers
a day wait wait and i also worked out
like a [ __ ] because they didn't
have a bathroom they had a bathroom like
a pisser so why didn't you sit in the
pisser i don't know why i think i liked
it i don't know just like [ __ ] out
the window is what we just found out
questions you just like [ __ ] out
windows do you still do that no
i'm an adult
i'd be afraid that i was gonna fall out
every time you tell that story i would
just imagine him falling out a window
as you're [ __ ] yourself
i just think that i mean
you're right some of it would be
complicated but for the most part i
don't think it'd be that bad and if a
guy say you are going to hook up with
someone you're not going to do it in
your car you're going to go back to
their place and then you just you know
real quick like oh you got to use your
bathroom and freshen up will you hook up
with a homeless guy
i have
i mean
i kind of dated a homeless guy for a
little while are you [ __ ] nuts
well i mean just for like it was for
just a couple weeks
and where'd you pick him up on the
corner bring him home give him a stab
and drop him off on the corner of his
[ __ ] tent he wasn't homeless when i
met him he was living in an apartment
and what happened and he got evicted
like right after we met he got evicted
he had nowhere to live so he was living
in his car
and so i just kind of would let him
crash at my place you know every once in
a while and take a shower and stuff
he's really hot and we had amazing sex
but that goes a long way
no it doesn't
now how did you get up
i just i just had this realization that
i might be coming off as crazy yeah [ __ ]
eat some more stuff please joey spot he
gave me
he gave me a star with weed in it
that's the star of death the star of
doubt
i really want to talk to those
rv people like because they all park
next to each other
i want to know what like there's one
over here about on oxnard with the uh by
the across from the macy's and they have
a whole family there is yeah up here
yeah and it's like they have kids in it
and just like they live in different
locations and they move at night yeah or
they move in the daytime they're in no
ho park in the daytime and they said
chairs out there when i go then do
kettlebells i see people out there they
you know hey listen man
if
i didn't have my wife i used to have a
girlfriend and she was cheap as [ __ ] and
she figured out having an rv one day and
i tell you what it wasn't a bad deal
she lived in a park that catered to that
so you move into these parks and you pay
like 400 a month they got swimming pools
and gyms yes and supermarkets
i know it's [ __ ] amazing i couldn't
believe it i couldn't [ __ ] believe it
but that's where she lived in renton
rent in washington and i used to stay up
there with it was a hike from seattle
but once i went up there i would stay up
there for three days i'd get weed on the
[ __ ] reservation
it was awesome it's awesome let me tell
you one summer i did this tour okay and
i was it was for like the national parks
and so the whole summer we camped
because they gave us hotel product and
studied using that we just camped the
whole summer we stayed in a lot of those
places and it is unbelievable it's
unbelievable it really is and i just the
reason that i think i would like it is
because i remember being the least
stressed out i ever was in my life i
didn't have a whole bunch of clothes to
go through every day to decide what to
wear i didn't have like you know when
the sun went down i go to sleep when the
sun came up i'd wake up there was no
like stress i just felt really relaxed
and i feel like maybe sometimes
overwhelmed with my apartment i look at
homeless guys sleeping on a bench in the
park and sometimes i think that doesn't
look that bad it just looks kind of
relaxing
i'm telling you it's [ __ ] crazy being
homeless and sleeping outside you know
when you go on the road and you're a
comic
there's nights that
you [ __ ] uh your bus lands in you
know pat and el pass on albany at four
in the morning but the connecting bus to
buffalo doesn't come in till seven in
the morning
and you're there with [ __ ] homeless
people outside and you sit there and you
smoke your cigarette but you're watching
them you're like this is [ __ ]
interesting [ __ ] it really is
interesting i love talking to them yeah
it's [ __ ] up to think about like
everything like it's whenever it's like
a bad like a bad one like they just
passed out and it's just like
that's like how long about like knowing
like you you don't have anywhere to go
like that's the craziest part well the
difference is there's homeless people
who do it because they have to and then
there's homeless people who choose it
like i was in moab utah and i met a guy
who was like the most homeless looking
guy i've ever seen and i remember asking
him i was like dude where do you where
do you live because it's so hot there i
was like you live under a bridge you
have shade and he's like no i love the
sun i just love living outside like he
just loved living outside like he chose
it so i think the ones you see passed
out are probably a little more like you
know drunk they're addicts and stuff
so back to the conversation at hand
when did you get into comedy
right sorry um so i started doing
stand-up in like 0.7 but i did it for
about three years and then i booked that
gig where i was emceeing and then i left
la for like three years and just was
emceeing full-time which i wasn't really
doing comedy at all but in a weird way i
came back and i felt like when i got
back to doing stand-up i was much better
sure just from being on stage all the
yeah and then i've been back about three
and a half years doing it since
i
saw you out a couple times
but the [ __ ] bikini things make me
laugh
and i didn't want you to i never
didn't want you to think this is a big
thing with me with women in comedy like
i like women in comedy i really support
women in comedy i know when a woman is
faking the funk and i know when a woman
is doing comedy i know the woman comes
into the comedy store and says i want
somebody to write for me i'll suck your
dick you know you just want to be a
[ __ ] star in two weeks oh it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's crazy but
uh
you know i used to see the bikini things
and i would just die because
it was they're funny it's not a broad in
a bikini it's a broad in a bikini who
just doesn't give a [ __ ] but to see the
white people around her and all those
little pictures the one when you're
dancing at the at the at the kid thing
with some black guy and you're just
jumping up and down was one of the
funniest things i ever saw when you went
and bought the printer
was [ __ ] funny thanks and then i
would talk about you to people and i got
to tell you man
you know when you go into the store and
you see somebody you're like you know
what
yeah i say a couple funny things but in
reality i'm just replacing that guy
you know i'm just replacing that guy you
know when you see noe gonzalez you know
he was replacing angel salazar you know
when you see different people when you
saw ralphie may he was replacing that
big fat guy he used to hang out at the
comedy store with the limos that was
crazy with the [ __ ] southern hat you
see the picture of him in the back wild
whatever you know you see these people
when i saw you and i saw you doing that
stuff you reminded me of a young felicia
when i first met felicia and then i
caught you some night at the belly room
i went upstairs for something
and i caught the last stream in the
chain i remember telling josh wolfe i go
you know that [ __ ] girl okay quickly
she's not just a [ __ ] bikini that
girl's [ __ ]
funny you hustle
you're out every night
you know you're not blowing guys every
[ __ ] night which i would hear about
you know
thank you
and that takes a lot to be a woman comic
you know we had somebody in here a
couple months ago and i told i know a
girl georgia who i love from australia
she used to be a comedian at the comedy
store
and she made a statement you know they
were talking about all these women that
get abused doing comedy how it's a boy's
game and blah blah blah
excuse me she wrote
you know uh
that's why i quit comedy you don't know
what it's like to get sexual harassed
every night and i thought about kate
wigley when i read that i go
you get sexually harassed
every [ __ ] night i mean you get
sexually harassed everywhere okay okay
quickly i love you to death but if i
would have met you 30 years ago i would
asked you point blank what's gonna rock
a coke when they put in your [ __ ] you
should put that bikini to the side you
know what i'm saying because you don't
look at women like that now i look at
you
and like i said i've been at the comedy
store i've seen comics come and go i've
seen guys come and go but i know a woman
when i know she's trying to pull a
[ __ ] quickie
you know they come into town
they think they have the they think i
could do this i could be uh you know
natasha guerra i could be they never
think about the work yeah and they come
into town
and they do this and this and you see
them and they make a little hedgeway but
they're sucking this guy's dick they're
sleeping with this guy and then you see
him two years later and they're just
[ __ ] beat up
like they just beat up emotionally
and they just disappear yeah
i mean the thing is i don't know well
thank you first of all uh
it is funny the sexual harassment thing
this is the thing it does happen and
every once in a while it'll actually
annoy me but then i have to go well i
kind of bring it on myself i mean i post
these photos and stuff i can't there's a
double standard if i'm like oh my
instagram you know one in every seven
photos is me in a bikini and then i
don't expect guy comics too here's the
thing though like i just started hearing
about you a few months ago i said like
with the periscope show uh-huh and when
i got here it's about like girls in
bikini yeah you're gonna go look but
even with your instagram photos
it's kind of it's not super close up
it's like there's girls out there who do
periscope and it's just all boobs
which is great
but
it's it's almost kind of uh when you
have a little dignity too and that's why
you're sitting but it's not but it's not
about the bikini it's not about the
bikini it's
it's a joke
you're right it's supposed to be the
reason they're like the way they are the
bikini photos i do is
for people that don't know what i do is
i go into random places where you
shouldn't wear a bikini and i take
photos
of people's reactions basically like i
did the church of scientology or like um
a
cemetery whatever and there were no
people in the cemetery actually that one
i felt weird about but but the thing is
that the point isn't for it to be sexy
what it was originally was just you know
i am not an ugly girl and so in my mind
i was like well i want to pick up
instagram followers you know using some
sexy photos but since i'm a comedian
there needs to be a way that they're
funny and so the the whole in a bikini
thing was just a way to try to kind of
merge those things but when you look at
the photos i don't think they're sexy
and like i know some guys do because
it's a it's a bikini but what i love
about those is i get more comments from
girls usually when i post those that
think they're so funny which i love like
everything i do i always i don't guys
are easy to get it's like you're a chick
with tits guys will follow you anywhere
but to get girls to like you that's
really more what i care about but i have
fun doing those and when it comes to
stage and when it comes to like my stand
up the truth is i just have i'm a
perfectionist and i love comedy you know
and i love watching comedy and like i
want to be a great comic and so
for me like getting on stage and putting
in the work like it's work but it
doesn't feel like work you know because
it just
i really like love doing it if i get up
three times a night i would get up three
times i mean we all would get up three
times a night but there's nothing better
than when you put in the work and you
can tell you're getting better and just
feels awesome it's just uh
you see so many people you come across
like i've been here 18 years and i've
come across
people who want somebody else to do the
uh what's that expression
some people walk the walk other people
want you to walk in for them
you know
i never heard that sounds good something
the one that i like to say on uh
[ __ ] uh the black dude with the piano
the pimp
it takes a harm it's a hot it's it's
hard out here for a pimp when you're
trying to get the money for the rent
remember that you're talking about
better yeah he says it in that movie
some people like to walk the walk some
people like other people to walk from
you know at the store i've met
when i first got to the store i was
crazy i was doing blow every night and i
could pick out crazy chicks
and they come to the store yeah i'm
going to do this i want and you're
sitting there going you know where where
are you coming from now when they're
attacking the career from the sexiness
part yeah and i go and i in my head i go
this chick is going to happen with it
there was one asian girl in particular
one asian girl who i mean wanted it so
bad but she wouldn't go on stage
like it was [ __ ] crazy right what do
you mean like she just thought i wanted
to stand up but i you know you meet
these [ __ ] people but the women are
really out of their minds there was this
one blonde that used to come to the
[ __ ] comedy store and pull me aside
and go you've got to [ __ ] help me
like you've got to help me and i go i
don't know what to tell you where did
you just come from
no i i got to be a regular here i got to
sign with three yards you know i'm
running out of [ __ ] time you know
and those people always creep me the
[ __ ] out this chick was crazy i mean i'm
crazy but not like not like desperado
well no but the thing is that i mean for
me when my stand up turned a corner when
i felt it turned a corner is when i just
started having fun that's it that's it
you know because i remember at the
beginning getting on stage and you're
like i have to be funny and my jokes
have to be good and someone might see me
that likes me and
whatever and i remember one night that i
got on stage and i was just really
[ __ ] tired and i really didn't feel
like going up and i it was kind of i
felt like it was kind of almost like i
threw it away
but i had so much fun i just didn't care
i went up it's kind of like what i was
talking about with acting it's not that
i don't care but it's like when you
don't care so much about the audience
reaction you're like i think this [ __ ]
is funny i'm just gonna have fun up here
then they like you then they think
you're funny and then that's when for me
it like turned a corner i was like oh
this is just i'm gonna just have fun up
here i'm just having fun up here and the
more i try to have fun on stage the
funnier my [ __ ] gets you know okay to
understand this a lot maybe some people
at home understand it sometimes you're
going for an audition
and
you have to have sheets in your hand
you know and i was good i always knew
how to take an audition go to the first
one
and then while i was doing the first one
i would write the notes for the second
one
because i wanted the second audition to
be different and better
so when i was going for my first
audition i already knew what i was gonna
do in the callback you understand me
that's how i set my [ __ ] up so they're
like this [ __ ]
came in with two different [ __ ] reads
both of them meaning the point
but what i would also do i would study
these sheets and i remember going in in
front of
maybe five [ __ ] producers like the
guy from drugstore cowboy the director
gus vanzant i remember going up in front
of
oh my god this oh
reuben cannon with wesley snipes in the
room for the movie [ __ ] undisputed
and meanwhile in the audition this is
what happened when i cared my [ __ ]
hand shaking from the nerves yeah me too
people at home you don't have no idea
what that's like when you care you're so
right and you're going for broke
and all of a sudden your hand will not
stop [ __ ] twitching and this piece of
this annoying piece of paper you hear is
what happens to you in front of your
future yeah this is your future you have
these five people that are going to
decide on that and right the director's
like listen if he's cracking
in the audition what you're gonna do
with wesley snipes is looking at him and
there's hot cameras and it's two in the
morning done
if you don't know how many movies i blew
because i shared too much because in the
back of my mind the back of my psyche i
put that this was it this was for all
the marbles this was going to change my
life
i stopped carrying yep
once you stop that carry and then once
you stop carrying you learn how to
formulate your six
minutes comedy routine
into those auditions which now it
becomes [ __ ] lethal
because you're bringing in a weapon that
nobody else is bringing in even if it's
a drama
even if it's a [ __ ] drama
there's times i go for a drama and i
won't get it because the comedy leaks
through and they're like what
we can't bring this [ __ ] hand i do
that too oh yeah the comedy leaks
through but when you're really focused
the comedy won't leak through
you know yeah my eyeball will be
straight whatever [ __ ] happens to my
eye will be straight but that's what
happens when you care
because you think this is the end-all
be-all and it's really not it's about
having fun and okay the first time you
read
your hand might twitch like that and
then the director calms you down and
says listen let's just have some fun
here [ __ ] all that noise and then but
sometimes once your hand starts
twitching that motherfucker's gonna
twitch till you get to the car it don't
stop till you put your hands still and
you're like [ __ ] so true
so glad it's not just me
it's so true
oh god it happens with santa when i want
to go out there and kill i'm not going
to kill
give me two of those [ __ ] stars
and let me watch a [ __ ] tv game a tv
show before i go on stage and there's
nobody talking to me
and then three minutes before that
somebody come into the room and annoy me
and it's all over because i'm not
feeling it because of the star and i'm
not thinking about it you're dead it's
once i think about going on stage and
how i have to kill cbs's there this joke
doesn't work you know that sucks once
they put that [ __ ] pressure on you
that sucks [ __ ] dick right yeah
that's what it is it sucks because that
happens to like with that barry cats and
when i said when i went like 11
interviews before i got like my second
job
when you say like you can't not you have
to stop caring it's frustrating for
people because either a
they think they don't care like they
think they they're not caring but you
can't like you can't force it and then b
like when you're people going for job
interviews you can't really not care
until you already have a job so it's
it's it's hard to get to that point it
all starts with your state of mind okay
so
okay here it is this is your office
league
all right and i gotta come to the office
and write my name on the [ __ ] thing
and then knock on the door and you're
gonna come out and get me
when i'm out there breathing
i'm [ __ ] psyching myself up to come
in here it all starts at that door
doesn't even start when you sit down it
all starts in there because if i come in
correctly and i sit down
listen man you could smell it you ever
smell something on somebody you you
definitely know when a guy wants to [ __ ]
you guys
okay
you know when i was when i was a
salesman they'd say don't
let people know you have to pay the rent
yeah totally okay i don't know i'm not
saying not that you go up to somebody go
hi i need to pay the rent this month no
it comes out to your body language it
comes out to your energy
so sometimes it all starts with your
energy in your head i'm not going to be
nervous i'm going to go in there and
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] him and if i
don't get the job i don't give a [ __ ]
give a frenchman's [ __ ] if you tell
yourself that before you go in there
then you might be a little bit more
loose there's like a difference between
wanting something and being like
desperate for something like look you
could want like either maybe there's a
gig that you want so that's okay but i
think what it is like for me this is
gonna sound so [ __ ] cheesy but for me
what it is is i'm really happy i finally
figured out what makes me happy in life
and it's i don't base my happiness on
whether or not i get this tv show or
whether or not i get i don't even base
my happiness on like my next i if i go
on stage i'm happy i got to go on stage
i have fun on stage always and
i'm happy when i get to go surfing i
found things outside of the business
that make me happy so then
i look at the business as a job and
there's like parts of the career i'd
like to have more than other parts of
the career but at the end of the day
that's my job and that's one part of my
life but there's all this other [ __ ]
that makes me happy so if something
happens and i lose that job that would
suck but i still have these other things
i think so many people in show business
are just like
so obsessed with whatever making it is
that they just lose sight of everything
else and that's why there's that
desperation it's like i'm gonna lose my
apartment i'm gonna lose my car i'm
gonna you know and i think that's why
people care i think when you finally
like find what makes you really happy
outside of it that's when you start to
be like oh well i'd like to have that
job hopefully i get it hopefully i get
it but if i don't i don't i'm gonna go
see this you know movie with my friend's
life
in new york and you know at the end of
september and knock them [ __ ] dead
yeah this is all a part of my arsenal no
i get all that stuff that that's
it all starts in your mind
because people could say they could
smell the sense of urgency they could
smell your barracuda coming in yeah if i
come in here and i don't really it's
like when you go to auditions for
commercials they're looking for a chef
and you actually see a guy that puts on
a chef hat and a chef's shirt i try to
bang him and you stab that [ __ ]
like you really want to stab him like
you just lost
i'd rather you come in here and do
something that a chef would do like
touch his nose or touch the hat that's
what they're looking for
bring food and this [ __ ] that we're
talking about runs
in your whole life hey how many times
have you liked the guy you really like
this guy
and all of a sudden nothing's going on
think i want him too bad you take him
home
you make out with him it's okay he goes
he doesn't call you you call him two
days later now your desperado now this
goes on and on and then one day you go
[ __ ] this guy unless and he sees you out
one night with a guy that you're not
even banging he just sees you with a guy
and by the time you get home your phone
is blowing up yeah because it's better
to want than to have that's it sometimes
you just gotta say you know what [ __ ]
this [ __ ] and they're all over you
mm-hmm they're all over you
you're totally right it's it's in this
this applies to work the supplies so
annoying i wish it didn't apply to men
but it does i'm the worst at that i
always i always start out real cool i
play it real i act like i don't i'm not
that into it i don't care and then the
second they pull away even like a smidge
i'm like i gotta get them back i'm gonna
get them and i go too far and then they
don't want me anymore
where's tony bennett that [ __ ]
don't
no you sure
you give me so much i gave you nothing i
gave you two little [ __ ] stars you
guys eat these stars every episode every
year we do something i really like these
i gotta get something we're gonna finish
it at a one you're gonna leave that i've
been eating bites of it every like ten
minutes it's a little hard well you know
i don't do so i seriously in the last
like six months i've only smoked weed
like maybe three times perfect but i
want to learn i actually asked i saw ben
leave the other night you know ben right
ben's a great yeah i asked him if he
would like take me to the weed store and
teach me about the because i need
something that's like a little bit of
like a upper to help me concentrate but
they have that they'll just tell you
there
oh he i don't have to take a comic with
me
they'll tell you what you know i don't
know what to take and then i want a
sleeping aid you need a little
sleeping aids yeah you need a little in
the kind of daytime a little sativa to
calm you down to flip it like when we
when i was a kid there was a kid in my
neighborhood who who uh lee and i bumped
into a little crazy rich he used to jump
off robes and he got stabbed and [ __ ]
he was the guy from jams the guy at
chance they used to give him like speed
when he was 12 because that would calm
him down i think the same thing will
work for you you just your mind's
everywhere you're always thinking you're
always working you just need something
to slow you down to
organize your mind maybe a little more
to slow you down that's it there's
nothing wrong with you yeah
sometimes i feel like my brain is going
to explode like there's so much going on
yeah totally you know i know you have
insomnia too you can't sleep once you go
to bed that's when the movie turns on
and your head your life story turns out
at one in the morning yeah you're right
you see yourself with ben affleck as his
nanny and [ __ ]
next thing you know she [ __ ] teaches
you
you know
i just know this [ __ ]
i know but that's specifically that's me
that's what you have is a great
compliment man and i've heard it from a
couple guys saying that not only is she
really pretty but she's getting funny or
she's [ __ ] funny that's really nice
and then i see the other half of you i
see you out there hustling
i don't see you complaining on facebook
or bitching about me when for an
audition the guy wanted me to suck his
dick you know you know
listen all these people that suck the
cosby's dick
you know when cosby's offering you a
drink it's like side controlling jiu
jitsu you [ __ ] up four steps ago
you know what i'm saying if cosby's
offering you a drink
you [ __ ] up four steps ago you didn't
[ __ ] up with the drink yeah four steps
ago what's the four what's the first one
back stretch that [ __ ] fourth
step you know what the fourth step was
when you even talk to that black lucifer
when you invite you talk to that black
come on you wouldn't have talked to bill
cosby if he came up to you back before
all this let me ask you a question yeah
okay half of them were in relationships
half of them are married whether it
happens what's rule number one
what's rule number one if a guy talks i
like you i love you to death kate we go
on the road i take you on the road or
something you're never gonna go in my
hotel room as much as of course not i
want to see your little flying [ __ ]
okay
uh
you know just little [ __ ] things
you're right okay you know if you call
me in the morning go joe you're not
gonna believe this i'm in the hospital i
let some guy come up to my room to smoke
pot i love you and i'm gonna be there
for you but after two days i'm gonna go
okay can i talk to you for a second why
was he in your [ __ ] room yeah totally
where'd you me oh i met him on the way
to 7-eleven so you know what
i should punch you in the [ __ ] head
because
there's these things that you shouldn't
you know you shouldn't [ __ ] do
if you're a married woman what the [ __ ]
are you doing i agree with you a hundred
percent you know what i feel
uncomfortable miss no mr cosby i'll see
you next time i gotta go yeah so if you
if he offered you a [ __ ] cocktail a
dick drink
you [ __ ] up four steps ago it depends
though if i was at a bar and bill cosby
sitting at the bar and i walk up to the
bar to get a drink and he's like oh can
i buy you a drink i would totally take a
drink then and have a talk with him just
because i would want to pick his brain
about but then you're on time release
because he's watching you you're on a 40
minute lapse he's going to try to get
you out of the 22
right by the time he gets you to the car
that's 30. yeah you'll pass on the way
to the studio he picks you up your
skirt's half off no way what a surprise
oh my god i didn't know you wanted me to
eat your [ __ ] if not you wouldn't have
pulled up your skirt
i mean right no you have a point i would
never leave with a mirror if i know a
guy's married that's it for me i don't
talk to him after that like the minute i
know i just don't understand
what you're doing in the guy's room and
listen man yeah everybody likes to flirt
i like to flirt you like to you know you
you work in a bar you got to flirt sure
you know herbert likes to flirt but
everybody knows the time it gets shut
off
right yeah totally and that's the other
end of the [ __ ] cosby thing that i
was thinking about man he got to the
point where he gave you a [ __ ] drink
you know if you're in my place i'm
giving you a drink that means you're
going down jack we already established
it i gave you a line of coke we know
what time it is listen she's gonna get
hairy later we got an ounce of blow here
well the girl they never said that like
well some of them said that he was
helping him with acting and stuff but
what the [ __ ]
but most of them probably would have had
sex with him anyway totally i think
that's the thing is that you drug them
if you go back to a guy's apartment with
the intention of having a drink you're
planning to [ __ ] that guy i mean there's
no other reason to go back there so they
definitely that i think that he could
have [ __ ] up
don't [ __ ] around she goes now you know
it cake goes back to your house it's in
what what's that what's
pretty women
when she's trying to seduce richard
yeah
she's like what come on listen
i'm a sure thing right right that's the
best part of the movie when she goes i
mean this is a sure thing who is going
back to if a guy says to me like any
time a guy says to me do you want to go
to my place i just assume it means sex
that's what it means every time right
you go hold on let me go to the bathroom
and make a little girl's room freshen up
one day you take a pee you take a little
sniff make sure the coast is clear
there's no problems there's no
dingleberries hanging from your
underwear what if the coast isn't clear
then you gotta go back out and tell the
guy listen i gotta give you a rain check
cause my grandmother just died she had a
destroying how to go home and [ __ ]
that would never happen to me i keep my
[ __ ] so quick i'm obsessed that's the
same one that's what i'm saying you have
to be obsessive how are you going to be
how are you going to be homeless six
seven hours after the sun no you're not
gonna be fine six seven hours that [ __ ]
develops you got old condom juice in
there you know what i'm saying
no
joey
that would happen now if that was gonna
happen i shower a lot i you know i
shower a couple times a day now i shower
in the morning then after my workout
sometimes again and then sometimes even
before if you're homeless what are you
going to do but you shot well
campgrounds have showers
are you going to go back to the middle
of the night like [ __ ] uh
i would
i think i could make this work one of
cosby's victims
you can't take a shower at 11 o'clock at
night in the campground i'll come
crawling why not because that's how you
get stabbed and beat up
i feel like this is going to be you know
what's going to be cool about this is if
i do this
and i and i make it and i come out
looking the same as i went in you're
going to be really impressed and you're
going to i'm still proud of you you
should come visit me at my campsite i'm
going to say you're going to do a
podcast from the homeless people i would
not have you here if you don't impress
me
i love you
because
i just seen it i've just seen the demise
of women in comedy and i see the root
and i see the root you're taking and
it's on a [ __ ] fine line but i love
it you push the envelope it's not like
you're out there and i'm hearing [ __ ]
stories and you're out there just taking
teddy shots whatever you're out there
[ __ ] working on me now you go to men
rooms i see you in a lot of rooms that
you got to have balls there's guys
hanging around it's not like a library
with a bunch of women with glasses and
tattoos thank you talk about how
creative they are it's a women's night
oh my god it's so liberating drinking
his tea get the [ __ ] daddy i'm at the
[ __ ] haha banging that with jack
junior and he'll watch my drink
with jack junior you gotta watch your
drink that's that's cosby's nephews
renee garcia those are my dogs
no but you know what the thing is for me
i think i think the reason i just fit in
so well in comedy is because i was
always a tomboy and all my friends were
always dudes always how's your
relationship with your dad you got
brothers i have bad daddy issues
that's what you're trying to get i have
a brother and a little sister my dad i
mean he's still in my life but
my parents split up when i was in fourth
grade and my dad was pretty absent like
i'd see him maybe once a week but a lot
of times he'd blow it off and
um it wasn't until i was a grown-up he
kind of like started to really make an
effort to be like a better father
but now he's hilarious because now i
think he's trying to overcompensate for
that time because he's like overly
supportive like get this you have a show
on playboy tv right my [ __ ] dad calls
me and is like hey i just wanted you to
know i got the playboy channel just to
watch your show i ordered it just i'm
like this is the most disgusting thing i
don't want my dad of anyone to not watch
this show i don't want my dad watching
like i'm not naked in it but the whole
thing's about sex i'm talking about what
i've tried and what i haven't tried and
like my dad my biggest fear is like you
know my dad watching like some other
show on the playboy channel with this
dick in his hand and then like a
commercial runs for my show and like
suddenly i'm on the screen
but he's so proud he has his friends
over to watch the show friends and
family they come over and he texts me
and he's like we're all watching your
show and i just want to kill myself
so embarrassing hey man it's a different
type of pride you're out here they know
you're doing it
you know he was absent for a long time
and you talk to him every day now no i
talked no maybe like once or twice a
week we talk on the phone i talk to my
mom every day i'm much closer with my
mom
very nice do you feel bad about being
out here because i just wanted to visit
my mom
and she's she's fine with me being here
now this is where i'm gonna be for a
while
but like this is my my dad just visited
then i went to go see my mom and for a
second i was like
is it am i being selfish by being out
here
but i i i think she's happy what the
[ __ ] would she be doing for yoga falls
what the [ __ ] would she be doing yoga
for no exactly i don't know how many
times i've gone on the road and i've
walked into a small place and i've seen
a girl that looks like kate and i've
wanted to reach over and say listen
pack your
bags you have no idea what your future
is thank you you're dating this [ __ ]
chubby guy behind the bubba who wants to
you know
come here let me talk to you let me
straighten you out
you gotta go that's so funny you wanna
because you're wasting your time what
are you gonna do here you're gonna bang
a ups guy and have three kids yeah
obviously at the same thing it'll be the
hot mommy at the pool
take a chance columbus did go out to
hollywood shake that ass let's see how
we can you know what i'm saying yeah
then after five or six years if you
don't like it you meet a director and
you move back to where the [ __ ] you're
from and you have a couple kids and
at least you gave it a [ __ ] college
try yeah i mean the thing is for me i
when i was like six or seven years old i
wanted to work on tv like i told my mom
and i wanted her to move us to
california and so like my whole life i
talked about wanting to move to la so it
was like the kind of thing where i mean
my mom and dad are super supportive they
want me to be here i do i will say i do
sometimes feel a little bad because my
mom has lupus and so sometimes she she's
pretty sick and i worry like
i'm missing all this time with her but i
know she wouldn't want me to be there
because i wouldn't be happy so i mean no
i don't feel bad being out here
i what or i don't know i like it it's
not it's not like an overall feeling but
every once in a while i'll sit there and
i'll talk to her but like
she's like when like when when it's
snowing and she's shuffling at her own
car i'm like
am i being an [ __ ] but no way you're
just smarter yeah
you're i mean i don't know this is uh
this is a cool this is a really cool
moving to l.a story but the reason i end
up moving out here is because i had a
moment i was at a bar in chicago it was
right out of college i was working as
like a jack daniels girl i think and i
was at the bar and there's this old guy
sitting on a stool he's probably like 75
years old we started talking and he
asked me you know what do you want to do
besides this and i was like oh i always
wanted to work in show business like i
want to act and
um and the guy was like
why are you here
and i was like well chicago's not a bad
place i mean i got married i was married
at the time and i got a scholarship here
and and the guy was like you know
my whole life i wanted to work in show
business i always regretted i never
moved to hollywood and then i got
married i had kids i bought a house and
i was in debt and i never got to do it
this old guy sitting on the stool and
he's like it's my one regret and i
thought he was gonna cry he was so like
wistful about it sure and i went home
that night i said to my husband at the
time i was like listen i'm moving to l.a
like if you want to come that's great i
have to do it i don't want to be 75
sitting on a bar stool like why didn't i
ever go out there and so he was like
okay when and i was like next week i
literally quit my job
he stayed in chicago i packed my car and
drove to la then for the husband
he stayed there for like six months and
he kind of worked and then he came out
here and then we lived out here together
for a couple years and then we split up
where is he now he lives in new york
city he works in like fashion
you still talk too much yeah we're cool
like we talk every few months actually
it's
i uh
don't get frustrated i just can't
believe it at times like
i didn't listen to a lot of people but i
listened to a lot of people like there
was a select
people that i i listened to
when i was growing up i didn't have
parents you know so after i was like 16
i was out there on my own and there was
people that
i just knew they had life experiences
that i would listen to a lot of people
i i didn't know what the [ __ ] i wanted
to be when i was 21 yeah very fortunate
i just knew i didn't want to stay there
like i'm like i just don't want to
[ __ ] stay home like new york is nice
and i got this all to myself and i get
drugs and i get machine guns but
this isn't what i really want to [ __ ]
do i didn't know i wanted to be in the
entertainment business i like movies you
know yeah
and it's weird when i see lee and the
agostino and i tell them things and you
know they think i'm telling them like
the torture
but i'm telling them because nobody else
will tell you these things like how
lucky you are
uh
i did
ryan sicklers uh-huh the crab crab feast
when ryan cichlid was here ryan sickler
has a certain gift
you know why because ryan sickler lost
his parents at an early age
so he knows how to pick my mind he took
those stories out of me the first time
but the chinese guy was shaking down and
all that and we had a good laugh well
last week he tapped into a part of my
life
where i had a hard time last weekly i
don't know if you noticed i was a little
off last week i had a hard time with
that like i thought about it the next
day like what that was some [ __ ]
tough 18 months like i i robbed this i
it was like one story after the other
martin the [ __ ] the meadowlands inn
beating up santa claus you know john
lennon i was like
and i went home and i really feel
guilty about that part of my life all of
a sudden
but i don't know how i told my wife
tonight i said you know what was
bothering me last week
from 1979 to 1984
i caused [ __ ] havoc and i don't know
how to fix it
i don't even know where to start and
apologize like who to say hey yeah i'm
really [ __ ] sorry for my behavior
because i remember a thousand things i
did there's got to be a thousand that i
[ __ ] forgot that were just as [ __ ]
bad
you know that's crazy so you want to
apologize to everybody no no i'm not
saying apologize i just wouldn't know
where to start to fix that part of my
life
but one thing
even though i was going through a hard
time i took advice from different people
and i took good advice you know like i
took the good good [ __ ] and i ran with
it and
you have to really take advice and move
like older people will tell you [ __ ] go
for it
like you meet somebody who's old and
they're looking in the face and go hey
man you want to do something it's done
tomorrow but no no i don't want you to
go and make a plan and tell me in 18
months i'm talking about tomorrow yeah
this is the pressure it's like a silent
pressure you have to put on yourself
that's why i was doing that when i was
gonna i went to something i'm thinking
of going to colorado but i'm going to
let my friends go out first and he's
like no you're not you're going next
week you're going with them
because
if not you procrastinate right that's
what we do we procrastinate you know
we'll find every excuse not to do this
and not to do that i'm happy you took
that guy's advice
something in his tone something
just something you know i just remember
just thinking i don't want to be that
guy i don't just don't want to regret
anything i haven't done anything i
regret in life i don't want to regret
that you know so how long have you been
married at that point uh i got married
at 19 i met that guy i was 24. i moved
out here when i was 24 so yeah
five years or four and a half years i
got married super young 19. yeah that's
why that's my whole that's what like my
whole stage act is about in my whole
life is that i was married from 19 to
30. so pretty much like 11 years i was
married almost 11 years yeah
yeah so all the stuff that you're
supposed to do and like [ __ ] up in your
twenties like all that [ __ ] i'm doing it
now cheetos
no i never cheated
never cheating
you buy the books i wanted to for like
nine years
but i never did it but let me just tell
you when i say like
the whole time i was married actually i
remember thinking
because my dad cheated on my mom and the
whole time i was married i remember
thinking oh my god i have like my dad's
impulse to cheat but like i didn't want
to cheat so i wanted to be loyal so i
was fighting it for like nine years and
i loved the guy so much i still i love
him so much so i thought that i'm just
the kind of girl that would always have
a wandering eye no matter who the guy
was i just thought it was my nature and
i didn't really realize until we split
up that it wasn't that it was just
because like sexually i just wasn't ever
it wasn't working for us and so like it
wasn't until i got with some more guys i
was like oh i don't have a wandering eye
i just wasn't with the right person like
it was such a huge like mind-blowing
experience going through the divorce
it's like someone you've been divorced
right it's terrible it's like someone
dies it's terrible it's the hardest
thing hands down ever a major divorce
i'm like what was it a sad divorce did
you did you fight well it was a sad
divorce because i really we both really
really love each other like we still do
you know we were best friends from one i
met him my freshman year in high school
it's her best friends but and there was
no anger there was no no one cheated you
know it wasn't like that so it was
really difficult but it just came to a
point where we'd grown apart so much we
had super different interests i wanted
to be here he didn't i wouldn't do
stand-up like he wanted to work more in
like marketing and other just
he wanted to be in new york i wanted to
it wasn't working and uh and i think
that almost made the divorce harder the
fact that we were still friends because
i didn't hate him you know when you
break up with someone because they cheat
on you or they're awful to you it's hard
but at least it's like well [ __ ] that
guy he's an [ __ ] this guy was so
great that it made it a lot harder
actually
um and it really wasn't until like
honestly i feel like about six six
months ago that i really like one day
was like i think i'm actually over it i
think the whole last like two years i've
been dating people
just as kind of like a band-aid on the
divorce like i really finally am now
like oh i'm actually enjoying being
single i'm happy i feel good i feel in
control i didn't really feel that for a
long time no once you get divorced
it's like mourning somebody yeah
especially if you've been with them for
a while
my divorce wasn't as painful as people
said it was when it got to the kid
to the two-year-old at the time that it
got oh yeah of course tempers raised and
then you know it wasn't as much the
loving part so i got it
in fact i couldn't believe it like she
moved out and i thought i was gonna be
really in the dumps and i really wasn't
and i was in shock
like i felt bad
like i was mad at myself for not missing
her more
when we first broke up which is
you're pissed but at the same time
that's telling you something you weren't
supposed to be with her yeah so
but i still mourned her
it still threw me off my game like i
could feel it now that still [ __ ] with
me in different areas really
yeah and i was dating younger girls and
i [ __ ] hate it because i was 28
and all of a sudden i was hooking up
with 21 year olds and there was [ __ ]
a huge gap for me i felt like i was 40
and they were 21.
and there was a huge gap for me and i
would giggle with them and whatever but
i'm gonna do the ain't [ __ ] mean yeah
this is [ __ ] this is just not made
these young chicks like this
why did you get married at 19.
so funny so funny that you asked that
because i always talk about this on
stage too it's like the first thing
everyone asked and i'm not really sure i
mean i think that you know i was young
i loved him he proposed i remember
thinking that if it's either marry him
you know when you're that young you
think like well
if i make this guy mad i'm gonna lose
him forever and we were best friends
before we ever hooked up i remember the
first time he kissed me being like i'm
not really that attracted to him but now
he kissed me so if we aren't boyfriend
girlfriend he won't be my friend anymore
i mean i was like 18. i was like a kid
when he proposed i was like oh i guess i
should say yes or he'll break up with me
and i love him
so i married him i mean that was like
really all the thought that went into it
plus his parents were like very uh
religious very conservative and i wanted
to move
to start my career i knew i wanted to
work in show business i wanted to move
and i knew we couldn't live together if
we weren't married because his parents
wouldn't be cool with it so there was
just i mean it wasn't like a grown-up
going into a marriage and now the funny
thing is i don't care about getting
married ever again like
you will you think yeah you will because
now i just feel like
there
if i'm with someone committed and living
with them i don't know that i care why
would you like what do you what do you
think being married is
good for other than the tax perks
peace of mind
yeah for you
you're a loyal broad yeah not gonna go
nowhere you meet a guy that you really
like and you're on a tv show and
whatever
you know what after nine years you're
just gonna get sick and tired of saying
my boyfriend after eight years oh i see
you she's gonna say this is [ __ ] what
am i gone yeah and then
you know you might be right i wasn't
listen
after my divorce i was i'm old school
catholic you got one shot at this and
once you [ __ ] it up you [ __ ] it's
embarrassing you probably feel like
somebody i was embarrassed i've always
told people me too the divorce for me
meant failure me too somewhere along the
line i failed i [ __ ] failed this is
about two people getting along yeah if
nobody cheated and you treat me right
nitrate you're right there's no reason
for us to go anywhere
maybe let's go somewhere and talk to a
third party and we'll work on it and
we'll work on this when you just give up
you failed yeah i don't give a [ __ ] what
society tells you at this point you
failed you failed in human
and and you failed for different reasons
i failed
listen if you don't take care of
something in the beginning it's going to
bite you later on in the ass
if you don't take care of that [ __ ] in
the beginning okay she'll just love it
i'll i'll i'll do it for now yeah six
years in both years are gonna go listen
i do not like when you [ __ ] in this
house yeah it stinks up the [ __ ]
house
you can't do it normally that's a
serious conversation that needs to be
happening just just little things that
people don't know that i did with this
girl to be honest i didn't really love
her
marriage lover yeah that's not marriage
lover my wife now my marriage loved her
i was with my wife in nine
[ __ ] years the first one this one
this one before you got married nine
years she must have thought you were
never gonna marry her she actually said
that and she went home
and came back and i could tell when she
went home she got a little beat up
like her parents like nine years yeah
her brother got married the boy had a
kid
and i could tell when she got back
something just wasn't up and here's a
woman now when i did the longest yard
and i'd wake up at 4 45
my football uniform was on the [ __ ]
thing there'd be two eggs
and bacon and baked potato yeah and i
said wait a second
where am i to get this yeah how does
this work out what you know there's
girlfriends
there's
relationships there's people like okay
it's 12 45
let me come over and then i do my thing
for a week of course and you don't see
me for a week you live your life that's
cool at a certain yeah
then there's the
you know the the
boyfriend girlfriend you make your own
car payment i make my own you live at
your place i live my own
and then there's the [ __ ] that
moves and says kate i love you to death
listen do me a favor
go pursue comedy i got this
but you only make nine bucks an hour i
got this
and he gets an extra job and they work
for you and they cover it but i already
had that guy once so i know i don't
think i'm ever going to have that yeah
you will i feel like you only get that
one no no no no no no no if you wait for
it yeah listen if you wait for a
fastball
it'll come my man is a [ __ ] baseball
fan here
you wait for that fastball and you don't
swing they're going to throw some curves
again they're going to strike you out a
few times but you're going to get that
he's going to break down and throw that
fastball at you yeah you're right and
you always just stick it out you never
know man you're a pretty girl i mean i
can't see you not hooking up with the
right guy again you hook up with some
comedian and you go home and you know i
gotta spot the store and he's at [ __ ]
barney's beanery
then it's not gonna [ __ ] work what
i'm saying no comics i feel like uh i
feel like i've said it so many times now
that it's finally like out there no
comics no comics no but what's funny is
um
i get messages all the time of course
from comics that i don't know
and they'll ask me out and the first
thing i say is i'll just go hey you know
i don't date comics and it's hilarious
because every comic is like oh i'm not a
comic i'm a writer oh i'm not a comic
i'm an actor oh i'm not really i don't
really do stand-up i mean i just i only
do the improv but you never really see
me like everybody it's just so funny how
fast people are not comics they're
trying to sleep with a comic i won't do
i can't do it and i don't want to either
because it's too much like the other
night i went out with a guy who's not a
comic he's in the business so he's in
the business enough to like get it and
like get what we do
but it was kind of refreshing to not
just like you know talk about wait till
you got one account i couldn't do that i
killed myself no you wouldn't i couldn't
do
this
you know why
because now it's something different
because there's not come a point see
right now you're in love with comedy
comedy is your [ __ ] every thought you
wake up in the morning you think you're
[ __ ] the squeezing's gonna load out
of your monkey washing it and then
getting on the stage
you really do we were talking about the
passion you fall in love with kelly
you're right there's a point of comedy
that you fall in love with it becomes
your girl for you to succeed and it has
to become your wife or your husband yeah
it has to you know and you get
[ __ ] oh my god people don't know that
that third year in l.a how you like okay
i've been here i've been there now i
gotta make different missions i got to
get different plans and you know i
totally you don't know what it's like to
cry yourself to sleep from wanting to be
funny so bad like
wanting not even to be a star like
that's [ __ ] no just to get laughs
that's it like you have no idea like how
hard it is to get like if you get two
laps in the set the fr like i [ __ ]
suck
i used to [ __ ] have a hard time
excuse me but
sorry that [ __ ] star of death is
going right through me [ __ ]
it's uh
you're gonna find the guy that's got you
back yeah and that's what you're looking
for listen there's people that you date
and then you break up you're young and
years later you're like why did i date
that person that person didn't have my
back
of course yeah we [ __ ] and the sex is
great and she let me put ice cubes in
the [ __ ] and you know we did this we
went to montreal together but they
didn't have my back once you meet
somebody who's got your back you're like
oh yeah you're right
you're right and now i can't let her go
so when i married terry that was great
for me she was happy big smile on her
face not [ __ ] three years later she
walks into my room i told her the other
day for the first time
she walked into my room and she was like
i tell you something you knocked me up
she was 40 [ __ ] two years old the 44
when i knocked her up
she was happy as [ __ ] guys
she thought she was gonna leave this
world not being a mom
so the other day i told her listen
before terry i was with a chick
that had an abortion punch card
oh my god are you for real
if you looked at her she had an abortion
today
i was with her for four years
never knocked her up
four years of unprotected sex and never
know so you thought
you couldn't get anyone pregnant i think
that about myself okay yeah right
with terry nine years yeah nine years
nothing nothing no birth control nothing
nothing no no you pull out even or
enough pull out i don't even feel it i
just sit there electric
like somebody zapped me with one of
those big guns they just sit there yeah
right that sounds great whatever comes
out comes out sometimes it comes out of
my ass and it goes back and i don't even
know anymore i'm an old man
but when she first came in the room and
told me that
and i said congratulations i didn't get
sad i'm not so like she cheated on me
oh of course i didn't say nothing to her
i was like listen this is her hand
she's gonna have to come out and say
something eventually for like the first
three days i walked around a little [ __ ]
you yeah for [ __ ] eight and four for
12 years
[ __ ] loads
and nobody's getting knocked up i mean
in horseshoes
you know so now you got to think oh no
dog i'm a big [ __ ] dude you know what
i'm gonna announce is gonna come out i
come in here it's gonna go and [ __ ] it's
like oh my god it's like eight nine ten
ounces of [ __ ]
milkshake juice and [ __ ]
oh my god
you actually just freaked me out because
i never i've never been on birth control
ever and i mean i use condoms with
strangers but i never use them in
relationships and i
just assume that i can't get pregnant
now i've just assumed i was barren but
here's the thing even if you don't drink
you
no no so i don't get it but i did
i did for like three or four years in
college but here's the thing
is my whole life from when i was really
young i remember being like 13 14. i
always had this feeling that i couldn't
have kids my whole life i don't know if
it's true but now i'm starting to think
it's true because i've never gotten
pregnant but now that you told me this
story i'm gonna go find out this week
because i don't want a surprise
gotta go to yoga go to yoga they'll
knock you up
they just knock you out automatically
so what i was saying before it's so
weird that
when i hooked up with my wife
she was into the acting thing and then
she started booking
and then one day she came home and she
goes i'm never doing this again she
bought she booked a billboard
and like and she got some good dough too
yeah
and she's like i'm not never doing that
again that was the worst thing ever she
hated it
she hated acting she [ __ ] hate she
goes i can't believe i was there for 16
hours
since six in the morning
they ran out of water it was like a
shooting she was a union principal sure
they ran out of water on the set i mean
it was just one of those days i know
hottest day of the month in july
sunscreen she had to get hit with water
a thousand times right and she's like
i'm never doing this thing i'm not doing
the auditions i'm not going to acting
class
so our home became something different
it didn't become a home of two people
talking about the same stupidity
ninety percent of the stuff i do is to
thwart
what we do
because i know how bad it is when it's
on your mind all day when you wake up
and it's on your mind and you smoke a
joint it's on your mind yeah after you
have sex it's on your mind
and a little comedy gets on your mind
yeah so after a while one day you're
like you know what for me to get better
at comedy i have to step away from it so
i'm gonna go do something where there's
no comics when nobody even knows
yeah when they don't talk to me about
this [ __ ] they talk to me about it's a
pottery class and crenshaw that's
perfect because that's why i tell it's
like bringing a phone into a gym you're
not accomplishing nothing yeah leave the
phone you can't leave in the car the
[ __ ] phone will burn the deck
so you got to leave it like in your
locker because then it's your hour
that's not looking at the phone going oh
my god i got it now some idiot calls you
says i want to help you right in 20
minutes now
it [ __ ] with your workout i always tell
people that when you're creative that's
when i go and i get up and go to that
gym in the morning when i'm doing jiu
jitsu and i'm hoping i'm in my back i'm
thinking of joking the whole time yeah
the whole [ __ ] time it's opening yeah
yeah so it's just so weird how i always
look for that so i don't my mind and
that's what i liked about
dating terry after like three years
that now we have become a house so now
after like five years
when somebody would make me an offer i
would go to my wife and go listen this
is the offer i got my wife would have
nope
yeah and i go why and she go wow
she was right but i wouldn't think about
it that way if i had an actress wife i
would have taken that [ __ ] stupid job
yeah got [ __ ] in the ass because we
got two [ __ ] living in the [ __ ]
house yeah one
so do you understand that yeah that's
true i didn't want somebody yeah and i
didn't know
i'm lying to you you know when i started
dating terry she was doing she was a
waitress and she was trying to act
so but i now that i have a i'm in a
relationship where 90 of our
conversation isn't i wanted to see john
lewis today and he didn't cast me and oh
my god well i had the worst day of my
life too
[ __ ] you yeah you know john caparulo
said that shane would walk in the house
when he was watching the sports center
and get in front of the tv and start
going
my joke bombed
and you're like ah
yeah yeah listen to the joke i said i
said it this way but then i didn't say
it this was right this way it would be
all you would talk it would just be all
encompassing yeah yeah you're right even
if you're with a guy that's in the
business he's an agent it's still going
to go home to this chitchat and
eventually we're going to go i don't
want to [ __ ] do this you're totally
right you know can you imagine if paula
was in this [ __ ] no it's great it's
great you go home and talk to her about
law and [ __ ] dilemmas and
opening up a gey spot for mexicans when
you say god compared to 19 like i i
think about how it would have like i
think about the girls i dated when i was
like i thought i was in love with them
and like if i like i never use condoms
like if i had gotten one of them
pregnant
it's just you get you get so lucky but
don't
listen man i could lie to you and tell
you when i was 18 years old
because of the situation i had been
losing my mom and stuff there was
nothing i wanted to do more to get
married at 18.
there was a girl i had my eye on i was
just waiting to manipulate this girl
oh [ __ ] yeah i love this girl with all
my heart
so that's how it was and i mean my
step-sister same thing like her whole
life she just wanted to get married have
kids that's all she ever when she was
little she just i remember her always
saying like i can't wait to be a mom she
just couldn't wait and then when she got
married had kids that's it for her like
that's that's fulfilling for her and
that's i just thought that it was the
way to do things yeah that's the way i
was brought up that you meet somebody
you love
and i didn't
i loved it
we were liking kind of a relationship
but in the back of my mind i'm like i
like to hook up with her and get this
party started like i want to get off get
out of this life i want this life so i i
could see why she got married in 1918.
i could see it man i know people were
still married since high school oh no i
i can see i'm just saying thank god i
didn't do it it's crazy it's [ __ ]
crazy she's like a catholic girl now i
understand why you're so crazy because
they shut you down from 19 to 30. those
are your [ __ ] that's why i'm crazy
now and that's also why i i suck at like
general life because it's not just
dating i mean i talk about it with
dating but my ex god bless him i swear
to god joey he did
everything he did everything like he
cooked he cleaned he paid the bills he
took care of like taxes like all the
logistical stuff in life that you have
to do i never
did it in my 20s i didn't even know how
to do laundry i did laundry for the
first time i'm not kidding you like a
month ago i'd never done laundry after
the divorce i was like i don't know how
to do this i would just take it to fluff
and fold all the time and it's not like
i was spoiled it's not like growing up i
had to mow the lawn and clean the
apartment and [ __ ] like that but my ex
just took really good care of me so it's
been like seriously
a 18 year old moving out for the first
time has been like my experience last
three years and it's been insane i i
mean i wish sometimes that i just have
video cameras record like running all
the time because i'm such a disaster but
i'm starting to get it i'm starting to
like learn figure it all out you want to
throw it all away and be homeless
well yeah
because now i'm just like having fun now
i'm like oh i got this so now it would
be a good you're really good with the
videos
thanks you're really good with the
videos uh
you know you're out there and that's
what these people understand you have to
be out there
especially today you have all these
weapons available to you you have to use
all of them or take three of them and be
really good at two of them yeah people
always it's i mean look it's not like
i'm super successful in show business
but i'm working in show business and
people always ask me they're like what
you know what kind of tips would you
have for someone that's new in hollywood
or whatever and i say the worst mistake
you can make is to just sit and wait for
someone to come like your agent to call
with an audition or sit and wait for
anything like every job i've ever had in
show business has come because i went
out and like
got something myself like i made a video
and sent it to someone and they called
me in for something else or i even the
playboy show the way that i originally
got in the door at playboy is i sent
them a bunch of photos funny sexy photos
with a letter that was like you guys
should do a spread on like hot upcoming
female comics that's like a funny spread
and they brought me in for a meeting and
they ended up being like oh you're so
funny you should work for us and do
sketches but like i've never gotten one
job just sitting around waiting i keep
as many
balls in the air as i can
all the time like if i have a day off i
shoot something every day i take one day
a week now because kind of because of
you because we had a talk where you told
me you do jiu jitsu and do this [ __ ]
where nobody knows who you are and i was
like that's a really good idea so i
started going to venice once a week and
playing volleyball with people that
aren't in the business at all
but other than that i don't ever take a
day where i don't do like two or three
things to put out on social media
because
now in the world we live in you can
build a fan base on social media and
when you go do stand up on the road
they'll come no they will show up
they're very loyal yeah you have a
certain thing that you have to have
to be successful in any [ __ ] field
and you have it and it's not your looks
or
you're very enthusiastic and it comes
across
like your enthusiasm is uh
it motivates people it motivates me
sometimes your enthusiasm like [ __ ]
you know if you really want to know what
the [ __ ] you have to do follow kate oh
and see what kate's doing and then check
with the [ __ ] you're doing
like oh what the [ __ ] did i do today
this chick's got three pictures on
instagram
she's got [ __ ] a picture with a
bikini on a [ __ ] chinese restaurant
ordering takeout
you know
another picture i doing stand up last
night another picture of her in the car
with eric myers and the [ __ ] jewish
guy glickman going to a gig you know
glickman's a hustler too
he don't sleep that's a jew dog
old-school jew
that [ __ ] don't sleep and you
give him a topic and he'll write a show
around it and sell that thing to the
improv and if it fails it failed joey
but guess what we're going back in the
august 24 with the jewish show yeah
hitler somebody dresses up and that's
what it takes quickman works harder than
anyone else anybody i know anything
anybody
anybody such a hustler but
he has more [ __ ] going on and let me
tell you something i've never met anyone
in my life who's connected to more
people it is on
you all you need to do is give click on
an idea dog and check back with him in
10 days
it's so true that's it that's the type
of jew he is he don't [ __ ] around he
came on he came on my podcast one time
one time as a guest he's like this is a
really cool idea for a show we should
co-host it i could do so much with this
i'm like okay cool yeah whatever you
want like within a month quickman's got
us a network to be on he's got the
artwork done he's got a live show but
he's crazy he's crazy he's amazing
amazing and that's the enthusiasm you
need because yeah even though you're not
hiring
don't not hire for too long because i
might [ __ ] shut you down
that's glickman's fight and glickman's
doing this
from an old perspective like you know
i'm saying like
okay you don't want to hire me nick and
knight
don't take too long i'm the guy for here
but don't take too long because i'm
doing [ __ ] yeah and in about 18 months
you know we're not going to have this
conversation we're going to be having a
different conversation how you're going
to pay me for this [ __ ] idea
and it's amazing how you have to look at
at least i had to learn to focus it like
we had that talk a few months ago when i
was doing uber like for a few weeks
and you're like if you if you put that
time into like something for yourself
you'd make way more money i am sick and
tired of people going i'm a photographer
but in the meantime i'm waiting tables
you know what
you lost a battle with this [ __ ]
safety net you want to be a photographer
let's start here go take pictures put
them on the [ __ ] fly make 100 flies
and go to every coffee shop
and pass them out 100 flies a day
i guarantee you'll get a call a day
that's it that is i guarantee you'll get
a call a day and you don't that that
effort you're putting for eight dollars
an hour and picking up forks with dog
hair and people breathing on you and
[ __ ] you put that into yourself for
three weeks
and at the end of three [ __ ] weeks
you'll be making a living and what
you're doing it might not be what you
want to do at the time but closer but
you'll be closer you might not be
running the studio but you'll be
sweeping it and at least you got your
foot through the [ __ ] door i never
liked that thing well
and that's why our friend can never do a
good podcast or never have a career
but the guy with the movie podcast
because there was always a safety net
listen that 20 hours a week you're
selling insurance you could be doing a
thousand things for yourself and in that
month yeah you're not gonna be able to
eat for a month bro
but after that you're gonna be making a
living and then and after that if you
keep putting the hustle into what you're
doing it's just gonna snowball it just
makes sense it just snowballs man and
you're going to have a bad month but
you're not going to go back to waiting
tables
you're not going to go back to waiting
there because that breaks you down even
more because now you're not living your
dream at all
now you're not really living yeah i'm
have to i took pictures of a dog on a
mountain last week who gives a [ __ ] we
gotta make a living [ __ ]
right and that's what i like about you
that you're very enthusiastic
most women depend on their tits most of
them depend on
you know you depend on your enthusiasm
and i really like it and everything else
is a cherry on the [ __ ] sundae
you have a nice body because you know
that's the way life works out
and i'm hungry
you hungry right now always well not
really oh hungry hungry i mean i'm just
hungry but you've been hungry like in
and out hungry no i mean i'm hungry we
will walk you in and out he knows
everybody right now
i love that and now he's the [ __ ]
general manager by practicing
so
thomas the girl was on a radio show and
he told the story about you knowing
everybody at burbank airport did he just
walking and just knowing everybody gotta
know everybody at burbank catboy that's
my smuggling route let me give some
shout outs here that's hilarious kate
wants to get the [ __ ] out no not at all
my main man cody wilson alex castino
alan hill
matthew knowling bobby sharon and
crystal for coming out last night hooky
spooky for coming out last night david
wilder
albert jiminez ernie lever
david cole jr and my man
corey rook
you bad [ __ ]
start off the week with a tremendous
shout out but that's the truth i've
always said that because i did it for a
long time i would make those excuses i'm
doing calmly but i'm doing this part
time
and that part-time you could be writing
jokes and making calls to get you into a
comedy club or a ride here and you're
just wasting your [ __ ] time and
nowadays you never know what is going to
be the thing that kind of breaks you or
suddenly gets you a bunch of fans and if
you're at a if you're waiting tables
when someone calls you for that thing i
mean
like i
i don't know for me i am obsessed with
keeping my time open so i always i try
to find ways to make money um
through social media now like it's you
can do it you know if you find a good
idea that's funny you pick you you have
a periscope you know you pick avenue you
get on there you build a following you
can make money now you can get sponsors
there's just so many ways now to like go
around having like a job it's a clock in
and out and a side gig and
and for me i love it because then you
get a phone call just even come shoot a
sketch that pays 75 bucks it pays almost
nothing but who cares because it's
something you do
i've had a couple of those that'll like
go viral you know and i'll pick up a
bunch of followers or something so
i just feel like nowadays there's too
many ways that if you are smart at all
you can find a way to make money doing
what you want you really can't at least
i don't know i i think you can even if i
was going to drive an uber you know what
i would do i would periscope and i would
find a way to make like driving an uber
into a show i wanted to do an uber last
week with me and leo me as lee's uber
manager
and we let leigh pick people up as uber
and we tape them like that show on hbo
right but then they have to sign
releases and uber has to know we might
get in trouble why does uber have to
know because uber eventually will
[ __ ] know that we're
in the car with me and lee and we're
picking up people and i'm just driving
coach we make a left but if they sign
releases who cares right the passengers
why have a tv show and then three years
later uber shows up with a bill yeah
that's true i think we can go to uber
and just pick people up and then driving
places and me and you together as a team
why don't you just put a mustache on the
front of your car and just grab people
because they'll just think you're
lifting 60 40. you know what i'm saying
you know we do because i'm putting the
deal together that's hysterical that's a
great idea it is a great almost called
you last week in boston why didn't you
because you're busy at the [ __ ] game
with mom
do you ever feel irritated because you
have so many ideas you want to do i have
so many things i want to do it like
makes me tired thinking about it and
then i i can't stop like it's endless
the [ __ ] that's in my mind sometimes i
know and then they all seem like such
amazing likes
after midnight my jokes are brilliant
then when i wake up in the morning i
look at them and i'm like oh that was i
don't
see that i [ __ ] get up and open up
like thai tennis places and [ __ ] like
i'm always looking for the next hot
thing you know i think i have a sun
tanning booth with a yoga spot next door
or something but yeah at the same time
you snap out of your stupidity and
you're like [ __ ] this noise i'm a comic
but yeah well [ __ ] comics yeah and
the only way to become a really good
comic is to commit and the more you
[ __ ] commit the more you get better
you know when i see a comic and he's
telling me listen i'm thinking of
directing a short that's the party's
over for me yeah you know how did you
become a director dog you barely do
eight minutes at the store all of a
sudden now you're a [ __ ] director you
know i'm a comic yeah and i can sit here
and tell lee lee let's do something
we'll be producing i ever come to you
with that [ __ ] no i'm a cop
i don't know about that other [ __ ] i
don't want to be a mom a director is a
director yeah a guy is a director the
same way you woke up when you were six
at night six in the morning you wanted
to be a director you want to be a
[ __ ] actress when you're six you're
like you know what i think i could be a
director and you feel it you grow with
it this [ __ ] that's happening now
people showing up i got i got a thing
last week i got oh i got a great package
last week i got a package on gmail
this is the movie i did it's [ __ ]
tremendous the movie i wrote as an
academy award winner this is only needs
joey diaz i look at the other thing it's
on vimeo that's a giveaway right there
you didn't do nothing with this [ __ ]
movie a bunch of people yelling jumping
up and down and [ __ ]
but he said he sends me four emails in a
row
this is it i sent the package to the
agent and oh by the way you have to put
this audition on tape for me and i go
before we do anything how much ghee this
is involved here because papa got miles
defeat i never heard from the guy again
huh that's how quick because there's
strokes yeah everybody's a [ __ ]
director they got a camera they do this
oh i seen pulp fiction i seen clerks who
gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] about
kevin's right yeah i told you he's a
he's a [ __ ] 80 he's a 90s director
when nothing matters he ain't gonna go
down into the sam weiss mom and all
those [ __ ]
you're a little [ __ ] confused for
that [ __ ] what night does your show
come on the playboy tv show it's on uh
saturday nights at 10 p.m good for you
that's a good yeah
i'm really proud of you a good lady
i know you work hard and i just want to
introduce you to the audience that uh
you're gonna be doing things and it's
not because all your god-given talents
your enthusiasm is [ __ ]
you know and i know i know what it's
like to just uh wake up in the morning
with your dick card going i'm gonna go
out there and [ __ ] mangle somebody
that's exactly how i feel and then they
start cutting your legs off and you lose
and then you put you know you learn how
to take your energy and you just flow
that one or two things
what do you think lee what do you got on
an agenda this week you got flying zoo
radio you got [ __ ] tank tops
you got consulting businesses
this guy's got more business sammy
i got all that no yeah i got a
bunch of stuff this weekend you wanna do
another star no i did four stars why not
he didn't do four stars i did two four
stars two and the other one was like one
no let's see one more for [ __ ] the
jewish people it's monday passover's
right around the corner no it's not one
is passover it's like april russia
russia oh those are the worst ones one
september
yeah well october yeah no september's
coming let's do a podcast let's do the
sponsors and we'll get the [ __ ] out of
here okay
real quick i was down in austin this
week
on it is uh blowing up guys right in
front of our [ __ ] faces and all
started with this alpha brain
earth grown nootropics alpha gpc ac 11.
that's all great i can break it down for
you and tell you a bunch of [ __ ] lies
i don't know
beautiful thing about alpha brain it
makes you more focused but the best
thing about it is
it's got a hundred percent money-back
guarantee and we don't want the product
back
that's how good this [ __ ]
product is you understand me if you
don't like alpha brain they got the new
mood
they got the the shroom tech sport the
shoes talking about
if you want to fly
lee got sick he didn't take the shroom
checking meal i flew today i'm tip top
my goo because i [ __ ] two of those
[ __ ] after i had two breakfast
burritos at austin [ __ ] airport next
to the salt lake like a [ __ ]
which it wasn't serving brisket at six
in the [ __ ] morning did you
wait in line for
no you're just going to take two [ __ ]
rooms no they had no bob the barbecue
thing was open but they were serving
eggs they weren't serving [ __ ] the
brisket with the whole thing so i
settled for the
the two potato cheese and egg breakfast
burritos with a little hot salsa and a
green [ __ ] tea
iced tea from lipton stop it
i got on that plane like a soldier you
understand me yeah then they tried to
give me that death [ __ ] cheese island
with that movaqua turkey get the [ __ ]
out of here i don't want that
carbohydrate infused biscuit they give
you on american airlines and [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] blood for two days anyway go to
honor right go to honda.com right now
and press in church church c-h-u-r-c-h
you get 10 off your first order if you
stay on it you get they mail it to your
house every month directly to your door
and they take an additional ten percent
off who's better than you
my head's itchy that's a good sign
it's like your left hand
who's better than you you're thinking of
smoking [ __ ] you thinking they're
going to a casino you want to smoke a
little bit hit hittysigs.com right now
they got cigars they got [ __ ]
nicotine whatever the hell you need you
know what the best thing about these
things is 1200 guaranteed puffs like a
[ __ ] that'll outlast any hindu
cigarette you buy at 7-eleven go to
haitics.com right now and get five for
50. you understand me get the cigar get
the 24 milligram to 16-8-0
quit smoking or just look like a pimp
while you're doing it go to 86.com and
press enter joey's church
and get [ __ ] five for 50.
who's better than you and listen you're
thinking joey how come you're not
smoking vapers you know i'm not smoking
vapers because i'm high on [ __ ]
edibles but if i was to be smoking
vapers i'd be with the nailed the light
boys and so should you nail the life one
of the best vapor pens in the [ __ ]
business you understand me a tremendous
product 100 money back guarantee
something goes wrong with the call you
call david peter and they [ __ ] hook
you up like that
they're all sort of proprieties of those
scumi's hermanos which will take you to
[ __ ] death and back those [ __ ]
things those uh 250 milligram hash oil
those will [ __ ] you up completely plus
the little [ __ ] horcardo ones he's
got for mexican people knock yourself
out go to nailbitlife.com and press in
joey diaz boom get 20 off your vapor pen
which is 50 that means you get it for
40. you're right who's better than us i
want to thank annette i want to thank
kenny sings and i want to give a big
shout out to now the life of being our
beautiful sponsors but not as much as
the beauty that's in the room with me
right now my little
irish princess [ __ ] kate quigley what
kind of name is quigley thank you it's
irish
i know what the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing like this smelling irish broad
when they're close to me
i swear to god that's all i've dated for
years you can smell them oh i love it
what do they smell like guinness [ __ ]
i don't know irish
leopard smell that little freckled
titties it takes you to a different
level
i went to sacred heart school i went and
i played st michael cyo all those girls
colleen maynes
all those girls i love all those irish
chicks dawg i love them that little pale
skin and [ __ ]
that one
look look though i'm not well my my
grandfather's native american and so i'm
a weird breed that's why like my skin's
kind of tan
but i uh i have the freckles my wife too
she's native american really yeah with
irish but you like you're like a casino
older native american yeah i would like
to sneak up on it
most indians you can't sneak up on if
they're really an indian you can't sneak
up on it and that's that that's that
claim to fame you couldn't sneak up you
didn't know that lee i had no idea you
could [ __ ] be silent you could be a
feather you can't sneak about come on if
they're a real idiot they feel you in
the room i think i have that have you
ever tested this out
yeah like have you tried to sneak up on
indian yeah
i think i have
i feel it you do i feel people i swear i
feel like sometimes i think it's a ghost
it'll be a person
you know but you should go talk to the
doctor
yeah i think i need that
performing anywhere on the road soon
actually yeah um well tuesday night at
the ontario improv i actually have my
own show out there and bread uh williams
will be out there it's called the
hollywood pool party and then i'm in
phoenix next weekend at the lab factory
with gene pompa and eric myers so
totally everyone should come out it's
gonna be such a good show good [ __ ]
[ __ ] look at you see what i tell you
she's always trying to make a [ __ ]
buck
yep what are you doing next week in
[ __ ] for labor day memorial day
whatever it is they're going to the fair
oh that's right you got the tickets
you're going to further get stabbed
no bulletproof vest [ __ ] it's
going to be fun all right what are you
going to buy that
i don't know
you don't know nothing do you what do
you what should i buy at the fair
popcorn
they guess what they have [ __ ] fried
uh
watermelon they look so gross
you don't eat it fried watermelon i love
the fair that's the what fair the l.a
fair
oh i'm gonna miss that damn no it's
going on for a while really yeah i love
carnies
i just like talking to him you know who
carnies who's connie the carnival
workers oh jesus christ they're my
favorite what is wrong with you you
never talk you gotta go and you gotta go
you're gonna get [ __ ] cosby just
gonna join those dirty [ __ ]
don't take that going out with them but
that's what they do they dose you too
and they take you into the [ __ ] house
of pain whatever they got
next thing you know you're a [ __ ]
pregnant chick on a circus tour with the
guys
that's what you should do and join the
fair instead of being homeless this is
when i should have known that i had
daddy issues because one of the first
guys i remember being like he's so hot
was one of the you know the clowns that
sit in the dunk tank and insult people
until you hit them i remember like the
insulting clown and i was like
i was like
15
and i remember the insulting clown guy
and being like he's so hot like he had
clown makeup on but just because he was
such an [ __ ] and he was so mean i was
like he's so hot
i want to go out with him like i was
super into him i should have known then
that i was set up for a lifetime of
problems with men
you're fine you're fine do you see a
psychiatrist
no no i probably should no [ __ ] no you
don't have no problems they're on your
head
right
that's what's like hype just do yeah but
she thinks she's got an issue with guys
she's got a little [ __ ] issue i don't
think i need a shirt the issue you ready
for the issue with guys when you see a
guy that you like don't know
oh i always know it's just that they
don't like me that you don't say what
i'm saying
if
because lately you've been picking some
bad ones yeah so right now your [ __ ]
compass is off that's what that means so
when you see a guy that you [ __ ] want
i don't know
i don't want him
and turn it around oh say no go for the
guys no no i don't want you to say no i
didn't say no i want you to look at the
guy and go that's my type and go no
because right now you're the kiss of
death you're picking poison so we're
gonna get your compass back you're right
so i want you to go next time you go out
to a bar i want you to go up to a guy
that you would never go up to in your
life
all right check his hand down if he
doesn't have a ring i'm gonna do it go
to a guy that you would never go up to
that guy i will never like whatever your
type is this is again total opposite
total opposite if he's fat and you like
skinny guys right you know what are you
laughing about lee maybe she likes a
little fat juice i'm getting you hooked
up here right
all the chubby dudes like you're just
you're just like trying to like hook it
up for chubby just like just go to any
chubby dude
and he got he likes big guys can't like
guys that are strong
she likes those little everybody likes
how do you know because i can tell okay
you're a [ __ ] classy woman you're not
looking for you're looking for love and
you're looking for somebody to take care
and
smack you in the ass and tell you're a
[ __ ] sucker right about the end make
something
but uh you're also looking for a man to
love you and care for you
and that's that that the [ __ ] women
women are a [ __ ] puzzle to me
that has always been like we don't want
the guy that's right for us
as women we want the guy that beats us
and steals the car and [ __ ] my sister
we want to get crabs from her yeah you
want to fix them it's so weird how
looking back now i saw the choices that
girls i went to high school with made
and i see who they're with now
you know what i'm saying like there was
a particular guy in high school that she
was hot
she always wanted the guy that was 10
years old
that [ __ ] ended up almost going to jail
with a kid and he's never talked to the
[ __ ] kid so what did she do she
became a born-again christian to take
the taste of dick out of her mouth and
moved to florida and now she's with a
guy that she would have been with in the
beginning yeah he's not john travolta
yeah but he's not [ __ ] ugly either
you know
and that's when you that's why i want
you just one time next time you go do
comment whatever a guy that looks at you
says
just say can i buy you a drink just as
an experiment yeah
yes i'm gonna offer to i'm gonna offer
to buy a drink for a guy would never
normally eat never all right i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna do it and i'm gonna
report back are you racially and like do
you date any great nationality yeah
except uh i don't like blondes
for whatever reason just because they
look like my they look we look too much
little bit right but anything else yeah
you're gonna end up with like a greek
guy you're gonna marry like a greek or
an old school italian guys i don't know
yeah yeah like a mediterranean guy you
like mediterranean guys i like
mediterranean food
same difference i haven't been with
enough guys to i've only been with nine
oh ten now but what if there's like a
mexican dude with blonde hair will you
go with him uh
no because that just sounds [ __ ]
awful
what do you mean what about like a guy
from spain like a spanish yeah for sure
that good looking spanish guy goes
dancing with the stars he's like blonde
hair but he's from spain
oh he's blonde yeah like blue white i
don't know no probably not i'm just not
usually attracted maybe but probably not
but spanish like rafael nadal yeah
who's rafaela doll the tennis player
he's a tenant
he's he's hot he sweats
i don't have a comment
why i don't have a comment i never even
really understood how the hottest girls
i know
always have the toughest [ __ ]
problems with guys or they're so
insecure about themselves that they're
gonna get cheated on i never understood
that i got to start this yo it's because
the hottest girls you know are the
hottest girls you know because they're
so insecure that they have to look hot
all the time i'm speaking from an
insecure girl's standpoint that's why
they're the hottest girl because they
put the most effort in
guys don't like girls that put effort in
like that we like you to have some flaws
yeah really sure we don't want you you
know
well you're you're not guys who are
listening because i have flaws
everybody has [ __ ] flaws yeah no i
mean that's the thing though is that
like i always say
being a hot girl it's it's only a teeny
bit of actual genetics and all the rest
is money that's all it is anyone with
money can be a hot girl you get the
right person training you you get a
makeup artist at sephora you get the
right hair extension i mean anyone
it's just having the money and then you
know girls that aren't insecure and
don't care as much about being like
super high they probably spend their
money on other things
like traveling or i don't know books
what do you think [ __ ] though
i don't know
what are you gonna go home and eat that
garlic shrimp what do you make it over
white rice no she give me that's mexican
rice mexican rice what do you got for
dessert tonight
i got pudding i think what type of
pudding chocolate look at you you sound
like such a stoner oh he's the man oh i
love it
i got pudding no pepperoni nothing like
that
that's not dessert whatever i love you
guys thank you for listening to the
church and i want to thank kate quigley
how can they find you thank you oh you
guys can follow me on twitter and
instagram at kateq funny and you can
follow my facebook page if you want
there you go and lee i love you
[ __ ] we'll be back wednesday
afternoon
or wednesday night we haven't decided
yet
this is a great day today monday go out
there and knock them dead i'm [ __ ]
starving my stomach's growling jack
i only ate a little bit of cuban food my
wife made today